Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
as the scholars of Islam tell us and as
we've gone through in great detail
appointed our prophet
Muhammad Sam. Wasam as a prophet
with the verses.
And he appointed him and sent him as a
messenger with the verses.
[Silence]
He was appointed a prophet
with the
verse and the command
meaning those first five verses. and he
was appointed and sent as a messenger
with the verses.
We mentioned the story of the revelation
of these verses last night.
But tonight we want to examine the
difference
between a prophet and a messenger if
there is one. And what is really the
difference in the tone
and the obligations and responsibilities
between a prophet and a messenger? Why
is this bit of information important?
Why do the scholars say this?
First of all, the scholars of Islam
are of a few opinions
as to the difference between a prophet
and a messenger.
a prophet.
Some scholars like
the great
say that there is no difference between
a prophet and a messenger. Every prophet
is a messenger and every messenger is a
prophet. They are synonymous.
However, the majority of the scholar of
the scholars of Islam
articulate a difference between the
prophets and the messengers.
And in understanding this difference, we
will understand
the statement that is repeated oftenly
repeated amongst the scholars in their
circles and that is
If we remember this point,
it will take us one step closer into
understanding the difference. They say
every messenger is a prophet,
but not every prophet is a messenger.
There's a narration on the authority of
it was collected in a and also in
which the prophet
was asked
[Silence]
He was asked, "How many messengers did
Allah send to humanity?" He said, "315,
more than enough."
He then asked, "How many prophets?"
He responded
124,000.
This narration very clearly
distinguishes between a prophet and a
messenger because we have a huge
difference in numbers between prophets
and messengers. 315
messengers.
However,
124,000
prophets.
So we see that prophethood is much more
common than messengership.
Messengerhood.
And so when we examine the Quran and its
verses, we start to see this pattern. We
start to see that Allah does make a
distinction between prophets and
messengers. And he mentions them
together. For instance, he says in
And we have not sent
any messenger nor prophet to the end of
the verse. So here Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions that we have sent
prophets and we have sent messengers. If
they were the same thing, it would be
saying saying the same sentence
twice. So there is a difference.
So what is that difference? We see that
messengership is much more rare. It's a
higher position.
And so the scholars then
try to distinguish and come up with a
definition that is
to be able to distinguish between a
prophet and messenger.
Some of them were correct. Some of them
weren't as correct. Some were accurate.
Some were less accurate.
However,
the strongest opinion as to the
definition of a prophet.
Whoever is sent revelation to, it
doesn't mean whoever a a an angel
speaks to,
that is a type of,
but that doesn't necessarily make a
person a prophet.
For instance,
when the companions
were in the masid and Jirel came in in
the form of a man,
perhaps he interacted with them.
There were companions who had spoken to
angels. Does that mean that they were
prophets? No. The mere act of
interacting with an angel doesn't make a
person a prophet. No. But what makes a
person a prophet is receiving
revelation.
That is prophethood.
So
prophethood is the receiving of
revelation. Now what the prophet is
commanded to do with that revelation may
vary based on the task. He may be sent
to a people. He may not be sent to a
people. He may be commanded to uphold
the laws and religion of the prophets
that ca the messengers that came before
him. He might be given revelation to and
not commanded to share it with anyone.
It's possible.
And so
when a person receives revelation,
this is what makes a person a prophet.
A messenger
is a higher rank than that.
is defined as
[Silence]
and yourself.
Your cell
[Silence]
was
And so the major major difference
between a prophet and messenger is that
a messenger is sent to a people that are
fundamentally
differing with him on the of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. A messenger is sent
to disbelievers.
He has sent to a people who are
disbelievers
and he is commanded to bring them from
disbelief into ean.
This is a messenger.
However, a prophet is not necessarily
so. A prophet may be appointed may be
commanded to uphold the message of the
messenger before him like
Disam
was one of the prophets of Bias. He was
a prophet. He was not a messenger. He
was a prophet and he was upon
the religion of beni is
and most notably the book and the laws
of
the laws of misam
was given a book correct he was given a
zab but he was not sent to a people who
were disbelieving
he is sent to a believing people,
right? And a zabur works within a and
that is why a zab is
mentioned along with and collected
with
a messenger
but he was a messenger of ben is yes but
by the time Isa was sent to beni is they
had perverted their religion so much
that they no longer agreed
with the messengers on the basics and
fundamentals of the of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
and so
was sent and there's a big difference of
opinion amongst the scholars on whether
alil abregated atra or was a
continuation of a difference of opinion
the point isam
was a messenger. Musam was a messenger.
Ibraim was a messenger. All those who
were fought against by their people
on the issue of and shik and kufur and
iman these are messengers.
There are a lot of distinctions between
prophets and messengers.
Not every time you see the word the
rasool in the Quran it's speaking about
a messenger necessarily because the word
the rasool could be used meaning someone
who is sent but it's speaking about a
prophet. So for instance,
one of the
specifics
of a messenger as opposed to a prophet
is that a messenger
home.
[Silence]
And so messengers Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala protects them when they come to
humanity.
to bring the people from into there are
two options. Number one, their people
will accept Islam and be spared or two
their people will be destroyed and they
will be saved. This is specific to
messengers
prophets. Prophets are were killed very
often by benel.
These were prophets that were sent to
Bani Israel and they turned against them
and killed them. And Benny is had many
many many prophets and between MS and
there was never a day in which there was
no prophet amongst them. There was
always a prophet.
And so the point here is that a
messenger is someone who is sent to a
people who fundamentally differ
in their belief system. They worship
idols. They worship other than Allah.
Whereas prophets not necessarily. They
are sent to people. If they are sent,
they are sent to people who are
they are in agreement with them in the
basic and fundamental religion of Allah.
So we see that this statement of the pro
of the scholars when they say
he was appointed as a prophet
with
what happened here? What made him a
prophet? He received revelation. He was
not sent these words did not did not
send him. However, when he was sent to a
people that were disbelieving, they were
idoltors. They were polytheists.
When he was sent with
here, he was appointed as a messenger
and messengers have very specific things
about them. But there are issues that
are shared amongst prophets and
messengers
such as all prophets and messengers are
male. All of them. There are no
prophetesses.
There are no female prophets. This is
the sole domain of males. All prophets
and messengers are human beings. There
are no jin that are prophets or
messengers. Right after Adam
before that Allah but after Adam
all prophets and messengers all
revelation is the sole dominion of human
beings and jin are secondary in that
no prophets and messengers are slaves.
All of them are free men, right? Even
Ysefam,
Ysef was sold into bondage, but he was
never a legitimate slave and he was
given mehood after being emancipated
and so there are some conditions that
the scholars point out and these are
things that are you know common
amongst all prophets and messengers.
They call them the conditions of
prophethood.
But it suffices us today to know that
every
messenger is a prophet. But not every
prophet is a messenger. If we understand
this, you notice the words that are
chosen in the Quran and the Quran will
start to come to life for you. You start
to see the precision of the usage of the
various words.
Subhanahua
[Silence]
subhanahu
He was happy. Alhamdulillah.